the time has come noble Guardian you
followed parts one through three of game
spots destiny raid guide and arrived
here at the final chapter all the weird
mechanics you've dealt with and team
tactics you perfected have led to this
the ultimate boss encounter in the vault
of glass against a Theon x conflux so
check your ammo levels do a little dance
to limber up and let's take this eighth
hole down first things first clear out
the rabble thats hanging out in a
Theon's front yard there's this little
wannabe Templar called the gatekeeper
that you'll have to ice first wake up
all the dormant vex with your projectile
alarm clocks then put them to sleep for
good and focus fire on the gatekeeper
easy peasy but like a wise onion man
once said for the next stage take a
quick survey of your surroundings there
are two circular portals on each side of
this room and behind each one on a lower
platform is a sink plate that'll let you
open the corresponding portal you'll
need to split your fire team into two
squads team portal and team sink plate
when the gatekeepers about to die team
sink plate should go stand on the left
side plate to raise the glowing wall and
open the portal while team portal
finishes off the gatekeeper and hangs
out near the left portal when the
gatekeeper goes down team portal goes
through the portal to claim a relic
while team sink plate shoots the crap
out of anything that gets near them and
keeps the portal open claiming the relic
is a relatively simple matter of killing
another gatekeeper grabbing the relic
and then scurrying back to the portal
while avoiding Praetorian and other
sundry of X all players need to fire on
the gatekeeper to kill it so that it
drops the relic but not everybody needs
to go up to grab the relic one player
can make the run while the others hang
out near the portal firing the final
shots on the gatekeeper and then keeping
the vex busy as the other player picks
up the relic when the relic carrier
makes it back to the portal everybody
should walk through and immediately stop
so that the relic carrier can cleanse
the other two players who have been
whammied by a wacky blindness curse that
totally sucks called mark of the void
once everybody's cleansed it's time to
shift into a different formation team
sink plate books it to the right side to
do the sink plate thing all over again
team portal including the relic carrier
books it to the other portal to do the
portal thing all over again however one
player from each team peels off and runs
to the middle landing to defend the
newly spawned Conflux from the parade of
minotaurs sashay down the stairs now
you've got three teams of two team
conflux killing minotaurs team sink
plate keeping the portal up and killing
anything nearby and team portal heading
off to kill another gatekeeper and grab
another row team portal has the toughest
job but with judicious use of supers and
heavy weaponry not to mention a cleanse
when needed they should be equal to the
task when the relic drops have the other
player pick it up now the two relic
carriers book it through the portal and
once they're through everyone groups up
near the conflicts in the center to kill
all the leftover enemies and complete
the stage
checkpoint activated now for the final
stretch which is a doozy like the fight
against the Templar killing a Theon is
all about perfecting a cycle you'll need
two teams team portal and team homefront
team homefront sticks around to keep
both sync plates active and kill the
kamikaze harpies that a Theon spawns put
one player on each sink plate pillar and
have them kill harpies with vigor and
enthusiasm the third player needs to
also kill harpies by lending support to
whichever teammate needs it if you hop
up on the left portal frame there's this
ledge you can reach that keeps you out
of a Theon's line of fire and gives you
over watch on both positions when a
Theon is spawning harpies though he
won't shoot at you so you can drop down
to the top of the portal and kill
harpies it will keep this up until team
portal returns speaking of whom team
portal which includes the relic holder
must start the eighth Aeon phase and
each subsequent cycle as far back in the
room as possible a Theon always
teleports the three players that are
farthest from him and you want to be the
same team every time one steam portal is
beamed up they will arrive in one of two
areas jungle or desert jungle is a
little trickier because there's a minute
are waiting for you at the bottom that
you need to prioritize killing but the
approach to both is generally the same
rush down the stairs to the low center
platform taking potshots at the vex on
route once there the relic holder
focuses on killing the vex while the
other two kill the seven Oracle's as
they spawn yes Oracle's are back and yes
they still suck just as before Oracle
killing must proceed swiftly or else
everybody's gonna die 30 down
staying near the center of the circular
area allows you to see all the Oracles
and allows the relic holder to cleanse
you as needed once all the Oracles are
dead it's back through the portal to
reunite with team home front passing
back through the portal grants the whole
team above called times vengeance that
sounds super badass and boosts your
damage output but it's on a timer so you
need to make the most of it as soon as
team portal comes back everybody jumps
to the standalone platform between the
two sync plates the relic bearer will
put up a shield using l1 that blocks all
of a Theon's damage so make sure you are
entirely inside of it or you're going to
get blasted you might even need to duck
if you're near the edge so your head
doesn't peak out but once you're safely
inside it's time to go buckwild on the
big a for players with nasty sniper
rifles should aim for his glowing lower
abdominal section to land as many
critical hits as possible the relic
carrier keeps the shield up and the
sixth player kills as many harpies as
possible to clear everyone's retreat
once the times vengeance timer gets low
everybody hustles back to their starting
places team home front to the sink
plates and team portal to the back of
the room the relic bear should be the
last one to leave so that the shield can
cover the retreat and once everyone is
safely back in place the cycle begins
again and there you have it just execute
that plan flawlessly a bunch of times in
a row and you'll eventually be the
toughest destiny boss yet it's easier
said than done of course and if you're
having a really tough time of it
remember that these enemies including a
Theon are all level 28 so if you're
lower than that you're suffering a
damage penalty also like the Templar a
Theon has an enrage timer that you do
not want to trigger so cycle swiftly
stay alive and smite that shiny robot
devil thing I believe in you nay
gamespot believes in you some good luck
and happy raiding
you